why does it seem like athletes
especially in track and field just keep
getting better and better and better
because we keep marrying each other yeah
so it's not it's not data-driven it's
actually breeding right yeah I mean and
it's just is that true i'm totally
ignorant is that trillion decathlon I
mean did you break the world record or I
did see I should have known that but it
and is it training technique and or is
it you know cynically as a juicing and
loop and how long can win when are we
gonna hit the limit so that's like three
questions now it's okay it's okay the
limit part I think that's why we do it
because as far as we can see because of
the other things that you had said we
only keep getting better so might as
well keep you know we keep going to see
the limits except in the pole vault I
think because that to me is the only
event where the performance is dictated
by the implement technology so bamboo
poles to steal to whatever now the
carbon fiber whatever technology is
invaded next may help people go higher
why do people keep getting better
I have no idea I think there it's like
stock market in a way a lot of things
like this are where absent flows the
long jump was an absolutely terrible
year this year like it wasn't but then
you know you get someone that physical
specimen like Usain Bolt's and it's just
the fastest man in the world by a wide
margin compared to everyone else why
because he got exposed i guess i don't
know i think i mean we were talking
earlier there could be a kid manhattan
right now who is literally the best
athlete the world has ever seen but he's
not exposed to track and field or she's
not exposed to track and field so it's
uh I mean holistically everything keeps
getting better technology nutrition and
be whatever so it's I think it just
follows the same path